so storm goes beyond omega level and
becomes one of the most powerful mutants
to ever exist in the history of Marvel
Comics and it's nuts check this out so
this takes place during sins of sinister
but unlike the other videos that we did
that took place 10 years after Sinister
had basically conquered the world took
over the mutant population took over the
Avengers The Whole Nine Yards this takes
place a hundred years later so things
have changed drastically since the last
videos that we covered and not in a very
good way so this initially picks up with
Marvel boy also known as Novar a little
bit of History here this version of
Marvel boy was introduced back in 2000
in his own solo series he's okay I mean
in my personal opinion I think it was
just a an attempt by Marvel Comics to
take a Cree Warrior from an alternate
reality give him like insect DNA and
kind of make him like a blend between
like the cree and Spider-Man it was cool
Marvel boy does not suck he's fun to
read but that's just kind of my
perception on the character the
important thing here is that he's much
much older now know as a lot of you guys
are probably wondering with this being a
hundred years in the future why aren't
these people as old or even dead like
they should be one of the things to
remember is that when it came to the
X-Men on krakowa they had a lot of
technologies that came from the island
that allowed them to basically violate
death either it was Resurrection pills
that prolonged their life so there's a
lot of under the current stuff that was
already established that's just kind of
being rolled over into this and not a
lot of explanation is being given which
I think is a bad thing because I think
there are people who are unfamiliar with
the X-Men that are jumping on to simsa
Sinister and because it's kind of an
isolated self-contained story it can
cause problems but what is going on is
of course once they get to the ship and
they basically not only give the access
code for this round but the one that
actually comes the following week that's
when it's revealed they're actually
meeting with Destiny or at least
Destiny's on the ship and she's being
brought to meet with storm now there's
history here and we'll go over that over
the course of this video we'll make it
all make sense but Destiny's showing up
here things have gotten Bleak for her
because one of the things to know is
that yes while Destiny is a precognitive
meaning she can see the future one of
the things we've always talked about is
that her ability to decipher what's
going to happen is relative to how far
in the future she's looking if she tells
you something's going to happen in a
hundred years take it with a grain of
salt because a lot can happen between
now and 100 years from now but if she
says something's going to happen in five
minutes take it as an absolute truth the
thing about this is that she oftentimes
uses her own abilities to see the future
to kind of work for herself right to
ensure her own schemes and motivations
are satisfied first then she worries
about everybody else second so she's
like the most American person ever so
the thing here is that once she arrives
a lot of people have aged up right for
example cable is older than he was
before and in fact even his technology
has changed now the reason why I say
that is that for those of you guys who
are unfamiliar with cable we are not
going to go into the origin of his
character because I made a 35 minute
video on that and even then I was
cramming stuff in you'll find a link to
that video pinned as a comment if you're
interested but cable is one half human
and one half machine but the Techno
organic virus was always like eating
away at his body what's going on here is
that he's now merged with a kind of
organic technology so it's more of a
symbiosis as opposed to a parasitic
infection but for Destiny herself what
we end up finding out is that somewhere
along the line Mystique left her right
Mystique left to go pursue her own
destiny in the sense that she wanted to
help the rebel forces try to defeat uh
Sinister and his forces the X-Men The
Avengers the surviving superheroes
basically anybody who was under the
influence of sinister what's so cool
about this is that when she did it she
reunited Freedom Force and as soon as I
saw that I was like Freedom Force no way
she's literally like on your feet
Freedom Force for the rebellion and I
was like bro like Freedom Force hasn't
been a thing in Marvel Comics for
decades unless I'm missing something
Freedom Force hasn't been a thing for
years the the important thing here
Freedom Force was basically mystique's
Brotherhood of evil mutants reworked
into a superhero team and working for
the commission on superhuman activity
specifically Valerie Cooper that all
happened during Chris claremont's run
back in the 1980s in the X-Men but
Freedom Force was amazing back then I
loved them it was one of the coolest
ideas ever but basically mystique's
death right she ended up dying for the
cause and so once Destiny finally gets
before storm storms a lot older than she
used to be but do not let her fool you
man she is every bit as powerful as she
used to be and actually more so like
it's nuts how capable she is but one of
the things Destiny says is that with the
death of Mystique it's now changed the
landscape because where a lot of her
mechanations and seeing the future and
kind of manipulating pieces and so on
were to ensure the survival of herself
and Mystique that they could have some
measure of a happy life together the
reality is that now things are different
right with Mystique being gone and out
of the picture now Destiny's focusing on
the bigger picture itself how do we find
a way to end the rule of sinister now
one of the things to remember here is
that there are a handful of sinisters
running around right now back in the day
in Marvel there was only one but what
we've learned is there's actually four
you have mother righteous you have orbis
Stellaris you've got the main Sinister
with the diamond on his head and then
you've got Dr stasis right so one of the
things to understand is that with sins
of sinister this story focuses on the
influence and the control of the
diamond-headed Sinister right the
original Sinister quote unquote if you
want to call them that but again what
goes on here is that a coming together
of storms forces alongside Destiny
launch an attack against orbis Stellaris
just one of the sinisters that are out
there it makes the most logical sense
because the stories of storm focus more
on space than anything else but taking
out each one of the sinisters in turn
would ultimately allow them to focus all
their efforts on the main Sinister now
one of the other things to remember that
we covered in the first video is that
you had more McTaggart that her mutant
power was that every time she died the
the timeline reset and so what ended up
happening is that in order to prevent
that from happening or at least Sinister
resetting the timeline and restarting
his experiment that the original attack
of storm and her forces was capturing
the Maura McTaggart clones which
basically prevented Sinister from
resetting everything so that's why this
universe has just continued on the way
that it has as opposed to being reset
and changed somewhere along the lines
and so what this does is this
transitions to storm and her team
arriving at the death sphere now the
death sphere which kind of looks like a
death star is pretty awesome this is the
result of the work of orbis stellars
over the course of 100 years where this
guy was originally just a Sinister that
was out there that by using the
progenitors which are some pretty murky
Concepts in Marvel Marvel kind of teases
the idea that they predate the
celestials maybe they were created by
the celestials maybe they created the
celestials it's just one of those
inconsistent things that's been going on
ever since their appearance on the
Royals Comics back in the day but the
point is that with these progenitors and
the level of power that they possess us
that in a lot of ways orbis Solaris and
the progenitors have been working
together that what orbis Stellaris
wanted to do was use the power of the
progenitors to actually conquer the
entirety of the universe now of course
this runs in direct Defiance with the
diamond-headed Sinister who's starting
on Earth Conquering the entirety of the
superhero community and spreading
himself outward But ultimately it would
all come to a head with these guys most
likely Waging War against each other
such as it is that's actually not what's
going to happen here instead one of the
things to remember is that in the last
video that we covered that when it came
to the more mctaggarts which is to say
again Moore's ability to basically die
and then reset the timeline that what
had happened is that where the effort
was made by storm and her team to
basically take all the more mctaggarts
and then remove them from Sinister with
the diamond on his head so he couldn't
reset the timeline and then start all
over again the moras in turn were taken
from storm and then brought to orbis
Stellaris by Destiny herself who again
was manipulating everything behind the
scenes but with orbit Solaris having the
Morris at his disposal the nature of
this plan that they have that was formed
under Destiny is really ingenious that
what's actually happened here and for
those of you guys who are familiar with
Star Wars this would be very reminiscent
of battle meditation that what had
actually happened here is that Cora who
has the ability to amplify the powers of
anybody around her had Amplified the
abilities of Destiny basically moving
her precognitive abilities to a more
fine-tuned point where she could
actually tell exactly what's going to
happen moments before it happens the
reason why this is so important is that
alongside Cable's telepathy what it does
is it allows Destiny to predict exactly
what the ships of orbis Solaris are
going to do and then to navigate through
them and to get around them so this is
why I say it's very much a battle
meditation kind of thing but this is all
important because of the fact that when
Storm's team arrives here what ends up
happening is orbis Stellaris most likely
in a state of hubris ends up seeing the
kind of rag tag band of storm he views
it more as a kind of Last Ride of storm
in the Brotherhood they intend to die
right prepare for ramming speed that
kind of a thing and so he sends out all
of his forces but with Destiny at their
disposal and being able to move in
between all these ships a way out is a
way in and the reason why I say that is
because the forces of storm actually end
up moving past all the vessels and then
fly into the exact Docking Bay that the
ships are using to get out of the death
sphere in the first place but once the
doors shut there's nobody there to
protect the inside of the sphere which
in a lot of ways gives storm and her
forces free reign but it's a really
smart maneuver here because when that
happens what we end up finding out is
that in the initial conversation between
storm and Destiny that with Mystique out
of the picture what Destiny wanted to do
was basically wipe out all the Morris
right kill one or all of them reset the
timeline and take everything back to the
way it was supposed to be the fact that
her and Mystique could continue to live
some measure of a life is the only
reason she hadn't done it but the
actions of Destiny is actually what led
to the death of Storm's original
Brotherhood team in the first place so
storm does continue to hold on to a
vendetta and this comes to a head when
storm decides to betray the plan and
then orders Cora to kill Destiny on the
spot now whether or not Destiny saw this
coming or even potentially realized it
was just the end result of her fate this
is where she died and that was basically
it we don't necessarily know but what we
do know is that with Destiny killed the
rest of the team doesn't really
understand what's going on here and even
Marvel boy asked the question he's like
I don't get it we got here and then
we're not blowing up the Moors like this
is the whole reason we came on this
mission to blow up the Moors reset the
timeline and set everything back to
normal but the response of storm is that
yes this place is hell but a hell that
still supports life and thus supports
hope which seems like a nonsensical
statement right like yes we have the
opportunity to destroy all the mores and
reset the timeline but if we keep them
alive this horrible Universe continues
on and the people in it have hope that
things can get better it's like but I
mean you can make them better right now
by wiping out the timeline so I mean you
know I just wipe out the timeline like
it's one of those things that doesn't
really make a whole lot of sense so I
submit that yes storm has become a lot
more powerful but in our old age she's
also going senile and that's why she
makes the decision that she makes it's
the only way to make it make sense but
then she also starts to realize that
again inside the core of the death
sphere are the progenitors and that they
are astronomically powerful the only
reason they Ally themselves with orbus
Stellaris is because they had a mutual
goal but once the progenitors realize
that storm and her Brotherhood are here
and that they would most likely end up
destroying the combined experiment of
the progenitors and orbis Solaris they
would manifest they would step in and
then storm and Air Forces wouldn't stand
a chance and so in order to ensure that
doesn't happen and this is why I say
Storm's level of power just absolutely
skyrockets that in order to ensure that
doesn't happen that Cora under the
direction of storm amplifies Storm's
Powers even further right her ability to
control the weather is all Amplified and
then in turn storm Taps into the Magics
of her ancestors and then rips open a
black hole and when that happens it
pulls the progenitors and even the core
of the world Farm through right the
world forum is where they're basically
experimenting and all that kind of stuff
now the progenitors do end up basically
leaving and focusing on their own
individual worlds but lest we forget the
idea of storm opening up a gravity well
in space that's astronomical because
what you're now talking about here is
reality warping right she's a low-level
reality Warfare but she's manipulating
matter on the atomic level and this is
why I say when you're talking about
Omega Level mutants even storm herself
directly addressing this right to be
Omega Level means to be Without Limits
that in effect every Omega Level mutant
has a level of power that in some
capacity City allows them to manipulate
the structure of matter that's why
there's no limit to their abilities
right somebody with high level
telekinesis can manipulate matter
somebody who has low level telekinesis
can manipulate matter they move objects
around but a person who practices that
telekinesis long enough specifically if
they're in Omega Level mutant with no
upper limit then it's only a matter of
time before moving a chair around a room
turns into moving molecules around and
restructuring matter and that's exactly
what storm just did she used her power
to manipulate weather which is in and of
itself manipulating molecules even if it
only affects weather in a localized
space and she's expanded the sound to
now controlling the atomic structure or
the molecular structure of matter within
a localized space again she's not
Franklin Richard's level but the ability
to alter matter in a localized space is
massive but here's one of the beautiful
things about this or tragic if you want
to consider it that with orbis Solaris
realizing that The Jig Is up right this
is a losing game there's no way for him
to come out on top anymore that is all
basically over that he shuts down life
support within the system itself it
basically kills everybody inside the
ship outside of storm and her forces but
with storm exerting so much power at one
time she can't survive the experience
and storm dies and so this is amazing
because literally she goes out with a
bang and so in turn her Brotherhood sees
its control of the ship of orbus Solaris
and then most likely starts using it as
a beachhead and their continuing war
against the forces of the sinisters that
are trying to manipulate and conquer the
entirety of the Marvel Universe but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace